episode 27 hey what's up guys my name is
Jonah and welcome to episode 27 of
three-game programming in Java now
you're probably wondering what the intro
was all about and a lot of you probably
recognize that from eddsworld and I just
wanted to put that in there for um as a
tribute to at Gould who passed away on
the 25th of March on a last Sunday and
yeah unfortunately he he died of cancer
he wasn't actually like I'm not gonna go
into details but again he just he
happened to get sick and because his
body was such you know it was in such a
wake stay from battling cancer you know
basically a cold just killed him
so unfortunately that's what happened
and and yeah and I'm really sad because
he was such a nice guy and um he he will
be missed but yeah I just wanted to put
that thing in there because uh yeah just
to honor him alright so let's get on
with the episode now again comments I
never read them like I do read them but
I never actually like know down if
people want me to what what they want me
to do a bit but I think that a lot of
you guys a bunch of you at least said
that you know let's decorate this launch
let's make this launcher um I actually
look nice you know and instead of making
it you know and look like a application
thing like let's make it actually look
cool a lot of your guys also said you
know don't do that do a menu do a menu
in-game like a normal in game menu in
the actual you know in this actual game
and and I will do that
alright I will do the in-game menu but
not in this episode I'm gonna go I'm
gonna sort of work my way up to it so
first I'm gonna do this and then I'm
gonna do the in-game menu so that he
doesn't turn out but like I'm gonna go
forward and then I want to come back to
this I just want to sort of work
chronologically now so let's decorate
this first and then we'll go to go to um
then we'll go to uh the game menu so
yeah let's get started arm
whoo okay the first thing I I was
thinking about this and I was like how
am I gonna do this and then I thought
you know let's not be innovative let's
not be creative let's just plain pretty
much just steal Skyrim's menu let's make
the same menu Ascar I'm obviously not
exactly the same but like the same like
layout the same sort of template things
I'm gonna open up seem real quick and
let's just launch scarm quickly just a
launcher hopefully that it'll show up on
the screen record or her but well anyway
so you've got this like you've got this
thing with completely nothing you know
let's just okay let's just minimize this
and yes let's minimize that and let's
grab this and let's compare them so
we've got ignore the ads a little logo
up there as well that was that's what I
that's sort of what I used to as a
reference to create on that intro but
anyway uh actually let me just drag this
onto the screen yep all right cool okay
so at the moment we've differences first
of all the size the first difference is
the size this is about 800 by 450 the
way I'm pretty much measured it um yeah
but this is 800 by 480 and we sort of
want to get rid of that we sort of want
to make it completely look like this so
that's um let's do that let's come into
launcher and in our GUI stuff that we've
set the first thing we were actually
want to do is let's go into here and
basically at the very top of the thing
so write it right on the right under the
cap thing we got to go set undecorated
to true so in order to decorate our
frame we want Java to undecorated first
so that it's basically looks like this
now look at that no nothing you can't
move it in anyway now you can't actually
close it unless you hit quit I'll
terminate the button thing so now we're
getting somewhere
I can't actually move it now uh-huh but
will we will be able to move it when
we're done with it so this is something
it's a little better now let's fix up
the size so it's coming here mm-hmm
where's our set size which then height
so 800 by 600 and that didn't work
800 by 480 x time yeah anyway so you can
see that we've we've sort of done this
so the deal is now that we've pretty
much got what looks like a Skyrim
launcher the only thing that we don't
have at the moment is the background
first of all so we need we need come up
with some sort of background for this
and also buttons these aren't these
aren't windows G or Y buttons as you can
see there's a these aren't actually
buttons these are basically just text
and it's this is like a minigame in a
way they think of that think of this
launcher is like a game this is this is
yes it's a game pretty much you know
it's running at a particular frame rate
this stuff is it's fine you hit options
you get another actual window this time
though but at all this this is like this
is built from the ground up so let's um
let's do that so we're not gonna I don't
know how much we'll get done today I
don't really want to go into a you know
too too too deep of a tutorial but um
that's let's just start okay so the
first thing that we want to do I don't
want to close this the first thing that
we what sort of want to do is um did you
open not yet did open the first thing we
sort of want to do is come up with his
background so let's let's do that so I'm
gonna sort of do this before you guys so
I've just got photoshop over here and
I'm just gonna go file new and I'm gonna
make a window of an image that's 800 by
480 size of our I'll check that out the
buttons are 10 other two are a tenth of
the size 880 before you know
they don't buy 400 cool anyway so the
reason I'm making it 800 by 400 is um
because the width and height as they
don't buy 400 again you could use
paint.net but I just wanted to eat
something more powerful I hit okay so
now we've got this campus to play around
with I actually found an image this is
just on the internet I just went out
I just went to Google Images and I
literally searched for like I don't know
cliff or Sunset cliff and I got this let
me open it and I got this picture okay
so we're gonna use this this is nothing
to do with cliff and even know what it
is what is sunset so yeah let's hum
let's just drag it in and we'll just
position it sort of so that it looks you
know kind of cool maybe like that yeah
it's it's fine it's a really nice
picture it's gone two layers and
actually rasterize it real quick this
isn't gonna be a Photoshop tutorial so I
hope you guys know how to use it and I'm
gonna get the Select tool actually I
wanna make it yeah okay yeah well I
don't know what's called the rectangular
marquee tool and I'm gonna make sure
that the feather is 50% and I'm just
gonna select like a left side of this
because if we open up the Skyrim launch
a launcher thing again you'll see that
this sort of treads conveniently trails
off here so that you can actually see
the font you can actually see the text
let's just delete that and you can see
that we've sort of trailing off here
let's make a new layer as well and we'll
just hide this life and now and make
sure you just select the whole thing or
not not select anything at all
and let's just drop in like a grayish
color maybe even darker just like that
and now you'll see that we sort of okay
so it's not it's like it's getting there
it's not it's not particularly there yet
let's just select this again and refine
the edge a bit more I'm just doing this
on the fly by the way let's just delete
this I can probably hit yeah we can
probably just keep deleting in until we
get a desired result so there we go
that's sort of what I what I was aiming
out so it's not it's not completely
straight it's not like a linear wipe
with like feathered edges it's like it's
like an interesting sort of shape and it
looks kind of cool so yeah that's
probably that's actually probably enough
let's just go into here and color crack
this a bit so images adjustments
just spice it up with a bit of contrast
and maybe add some blue because that
would make it look really interesting
I'm gonna say green I hate green so I'll
remove that ah
Brett I'll bring the mid-tones growing a
bit up at the low tones down and let's
just bring the highlights down as well
maybe and red so red I'm just gonna
remove a bit of the red overall because
it's really it's quite red anyway
because it's on set
not too much though so it doesn't look
like a piece of crap
mmm again this is just okay that's all
looks fine
oh and let's grab the text tool and
we'll just type mine front because
that's name again I know this is
completely unlit it's like a little
romantic sort of image but um it's like
it's hilarious
let's 72 yeah well yeah well do it in
center that's nice fun maybe like 84
even and let's right-click blending
options drop shadow in a glow outer glow
should be Bellona voice nope no way I
don't like that one bevel and emboss it
kind of looks bad my opinion for the
inner glow let's just looked like a nice
sort of sunshine color maybe even like
an orange yeah I like that color and for
outer glow but can select like a dark
sort of even like a yeah that's nice all
right I'm going to adjust some of these
settings maybe turn the opacity of the
inner glow out a bit and the size of the
inner glow to like two so we can
actually see the damn text shark um
besides at the outer glow however let's
just bring that up a bit so it sort of
wants maybe spread yes you can see how
that's sort of really nicely coming
together and are we are we in bold
right now where's the UH where's the
we are where Armstrong hmm all right we
might I just want to beef it up a bit
you guys know what I mean not all do all
right fine so we got this
yeah the inner glow' sort of making it
hard to read you guys can tell it's just
blending options in agloe
you guys don't have Photoshop don't
worry just this obviously isn't required
for programming but um I just thought
I'd make it and look nice so that you
guys can see that you can make these
these things look nice
uh where's the inner glow let's just
turn the sides down to two there we go
and the chart let's just go do that yeah
okay cool so go this now um actually I
I'm I'm even like thinking of like a
yellow for the inner glow maybe like
yeah yeah that's not it that's nice okay
cool so let's just go hit file save as
and let's go into mine front and
resources this isn't really textures so
let's just save it and um save this menu
image or even like a launcher more like
a launcher image I'll call it menu edit
image save it and we'll just save it as
a PSD in case we want to edit it but
then we give up we'll go save as and
make sure you save it as a JPEG or a PNG
I'm just gonna save it as a JPEG as a
general rule what I like doing to be
honest is if I don't need transparency
then I'll save it as a JPEG because the
file sizes are smaller than PNG and it's
just this unnecessary to save it and the
colors of this sort of stuff will
actually look better as a JPEG so it's
saved make sure your maximum quality
obviously and here again all right so
we've got a we've got our image now
let's just come in here and take a look
at it if I can find it here should be
able to let's see here my
Alissa's menu image so we've got this
nice little image and we're gonna sort
of make buttons here later and yeah so
the the goal now I guess is to actually
get that image to load now the deal is
we've did the thing right now is that
we've we've don't have any way to
actually load an image and what I want
to do is because I want to make buttons
and I want to even you know I I don't
want to close the possibility of having
an animated background if you guys want
a background to do something like maybe
to move very slightly to live on and or
maybe a cloud to move across I I don't
know but if you want to do something
that's animated then I just I want to
keep your options open so instead of
loading a static image I'm actually
going to create a separate buffer
strategy for this and actually have it
render the image instead of just you
know show at once so in other words it's
coming to here and we've got this render
thing and basically what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna copy that entire method in
display and I'm gonna create again a
this time when I call it random menu so
basically let's get rid of some of this
because we don't need it we don't need
screen we don't need basically we don't
need a lot of this stuff all we need all
we need in this method is pretty much we
don't need this for any screen door
render game graphics we don't need let's
just get rid of all this cuz we don't
need it at all so we're back to this and
let's come in here and for the moment
let's just why don't we have render
written twice I don't know actually and
we've got frames written twice all right
um okay let's hmm that's actually weird
don't worry about the other let's just
get rid of render so comment that out
for now and then we'll just have around
a menu so that now we're gonna actually
render the menu and when we do render
menu well while we actually want to do
is sort of load that image in as you
could have probably imagined so first
thing I'll do here is let's make sure
you're in a render not render menu
swearing to run again let's get rid of
that and let's get rid of oh crap I've
stood them still in here Brenda menu not
let's just
- so that we don't actually see it
because that's getting annoying um let's
come in here and we'll just type J dot
set color to color black just as a test
I guess and we'll fill a rectangle with
that color so zero zero width and height
actually eight hundred by four hundred
thousand our frame and we've done this
now so what we actually need to do is
add this component because if we
actually run this right now what you'll
see is actually not gonna do anything
because that is a good point actually
um okay let's think about this for a
minute from a you know from a normal
point of view we is sort of we want to
we don't want to have to retype this
entire while loop while loop this entire
you know starting and stopping up the
thread we want to start the thread
basically as soon as we start the game
so in order to do that let's um
come into launcher and we'll just hit
display display equals new display so
I'm making any actually no mmm no no
let's do it a different way let's type
display display here okay and over here
we'll type a display display equals new
display all right so we've added another
parameter here let's just import this so
that we can then in here let's just hit
we can actually hit up display don't
start so it's going to start that loop
it's going to start it's going to start
that thread so it's gonna set running a
tackle true and it's going to start out
while running loop let's come in here
and we need to obviously set a parameter
for display so we can just hit display
alright
okay so let's try and run that now nope
options you just play all right let's
run run it Oh still getting errors what
are we getting errors in again you just
play all right so let's run it okay now
you'll see that we just crash right now
the buff strategy crashed with a an
illegal state exception now if you
actually look that up what on the
illegal state exception means is that
it's created a buffer strategy but
you're not displaying it in any way
which results in program crushing so if
we run it here you can actually say here
you can actually see here that um
component must have a valid pier we
haven't actually added in that buffer
strategy into our window so it's
refusing to it's refusing to actually
work it'll still work a bit like that's
a lot of errors but uh it'll still work
but you know we're not we're not
displaying that thing as you can see
we're still actually we're not you know
we're not actually um black as we said I
saw it too
now a rectangle do so let's go into here
first of all it's just we've got this
get component get content pane let's
just comment that out and so that we get
just a nice blank thing what we need to
do is we need to actually add that that
our instance of display into our frame
so the way we do that and we've done
this before is just add display that's
it
we're adding to this display right let's
hit this and as you can see we get a
perfectly errorless window right now and
it's undecorated and it's just
displaying a black solid as we wanted it
to okay so I thought reason actually
went over that guy's is because I'm I'm
sure that a lot of you guys will
probably forget this or you'll somehow
encounter this error and you'll be like
you know this is driving me insane
because this error sucks but once you
know what it does it's really easy to
solve just
make sure you're actually displaying
that component make sure you're actually
displaying the buffer strategy make sure
you're adding it into the into the thing
so make sure you doing that okay so we
basically I've shown you guys I've shown
you guys how to make a GUI launcher
which is what I did in previous like
three two or three episodes actually
let's see if so 23 I'm pretty sure I
started at four five maybe even like
four episodes but anyway in the last a
few episodes I showed you guys how to
actually use the windows style GUI to
make it now we're gonna full-on make a
our own custom launcher like the Skyrim
one where you can see that it's all
costume and I don't even know if you
guys can see this in this in the screen
report I don't see why you wouldn't but
uh hopefully you do because if you don't
then I'm just just doing nothing at all
um all right cool so a lot of imports
here that we're not using I just get rid
of this I just noticed the amount of
warnings here all right
three warnings fonts here at a local
fair okay that's fine we'll just leave
that all right cool
it's sore where was I am getting
distracted today we were at launches
okay so we've got a black thing awesome
now we actually want to load that image
in oh another thing I'll deal with this
in a minute let's just go into display
and what we're going to do is we want to
actually after we do this let's just
draw image so we work we actually want
to draw an image now so the way we're
gonna do that is let's just get rid of
all these arguments and start from
scratch
well what we want to do is we want to in
normal terms we want to load menu image
and we want to display it so that's the
way we do it we draw image the image we
want to draw is just simply image I
don't read if I open the texture class
you'll see that we use pretty much the
exact same technique here we're gonna do
we're gonna load a buffered image in the
exact same way so it's not actually
about foot image I think it's a it's
just an image but it's the same thing
image i/o to read and the thing we won't
read is from displayed or class dot get
resource and we're just gonna go to I
think it's in I think it's just actually
a menu image isn't a menu image image I
don't think it's any in any folders
after texture I mean let's just and
we'll have to try and catch that as
you'll probably say but we haven't
finished this yet
yeah well right in our resourceful
awesome JPEG PNG so we've done that we
also need to specify what else we need
specify yeah well obviously the location
it's actually minimizes and Bono's not
alright cool so that the width and
height the and the image of the Buddha
nice or null and we'll have to try and
catch this let's just sign it with try
and catch and yes let's check this out
works and it just crashed because of an
illegal argument exception ones that
mean all right so we've got a problem
here
it would seem illegal argument exception
why is that thrown okay so if there's
anything that I don't know just let's
just go sell the Javadoc first let's
make sure it's yeah come on it's the
only attached sauce all right
oh it's actually really convenient
because I'll show you guys how to I
showed you guys the API last time just
now I'm going to show you guys how to
diagnose stuff so we've got our input
output image IO which is right here and
we're using the read claw the read
method so there's a lot of them here
method detail there we go read so many
methods for read so it returns an
illegal argument exception if stream is
null all right so that's actually quite
convenient so in other words what's
happening is when we launch this for
some reason one of these is it's just
it's null like it's not G is it no it's
not probably the actual hmm so okay
let's get this right it's returning null
which probably means that this doesn't
exist but it had hmm menu image to a
page I spell that right in the resources
folder
but refresh this menu Mitchell jpg hmm
this is odd many image/jpeg I shouldn't
have to go like that huh
no I shouldn't at all huh hmm okay well
something's returning no its input
equals null it's right over here as well
okay so we've obviously got a problem
with the actual image not being ready to
actually put this in the right I did put
this in the right thing that's right
here hmm let's copy this and make sure I
typed it out right pretty sure I did
that own deny yeah I did
that is peculiar right now let's just
let's just try and fix this and
hopefully you guys will maybe learn how
to fix stuff really really weird
I guess so all right well our input is
equal to null which means that it's for
some reason it's not funny that okay
let's put a four slash in front of this
and see if that helps sometimes it does
oh look at that that is we marched quite
annoying to be honest I'm not sure why
the Frick it it it makes a difference
why does it make it different care I'm
not sure why sometimes sometimes it does
sometimes it doesn't you saw that when
we actually had our configuration class
open we couldn't actually put a full
slash here and it didn't work if we did
but over here we have to put a whole
slash I'm not sure why but you know we
had to here as well I'm I don't know how
this works it's sometimes it's just
weird all right so well is now which is
pretty pretty damn awesome so another
thing I wanted to mention is if we just
let's just comment this entire thing out
for a second one of the problems that
something like this creates is the sheer
framerate it runs out now I'm recording
right now with my screen capture
software so it's running at about 5,000
frames per second which isn't too fast
if I turn if I actually turn my screen
capture software off and I don't record
then it runs at about 15,000 frames per
second now you guys can't hear that but
my graphics card in my computer is
actually squealing right now because
it's having it's because it's rendering
so many frames this is not good for your
computer so we want to stop this
basically this is something this this is
very important so make sure you actually
do this conveniently in here we've got a
an if ticked method method which
basically what it does is whatever we
put in here it will do 60 times a second
so let's come in here and let's cut
render menu and put it into here so now
if we run it you should see that it
didn't work
huh in fact it's actually going fast
look at that quli all right the reason
is that this whole thing isn't actually
in here let's make sure that it's
actually within our while unprocessed
seconds is greater than seconds per tick
and we should say that we're running at
60 frames per second now
so we basically put a I don't know I
don't know what what to call like a vase
Inc or we've basically put a frame cap
on we've limited the maximum fps to be
60 all right so it's a lot safer now so
yeah let's just uncomment that out and
we should we should be back to having
our awesome things and now look how cool
it looks let's just get rid of this it's
starting to look more and more like the
like the Skyrim laundry which is which
is really cool it says my in front which
is Nicola I'm kidding um so let's let's
just draw some let's like draw a mock-up
type thing this is being rendered in
real time by the way so one of the
things you guys should realize so
whatever we do here can actually be live
updated because we're it's in a loop
it's in the wild running loop so let's
just draw a string
we'll make it say I don't know play and
we'll put it like how about why does our
friend look like seven twenty or
something and like 19 but I want
obviously set the color first to be
white and we'll set the font to be
vadhana zero twenty so yeah you can see
that now we've got a play button that
doesn't do anything it's not actually a
button but yeah and in that sort of way
and you can see that we can actually
influence we can influence that in real
time we just hit control s when we don't
all go you know we'll move this to
something like 110 I hit controllers
automatically like 90 and then we go
file and save and it will update on our
thing but the deal with this is that
we've
we've sort of managed to create a in
actual launcher with this this play
button that doesn't do anything so
that's gonna wrap up today's tutorial
but um next week will actually okay next
week we'll make this launcher move so
when when we click and drag the mouse
this is gonna like it with a Skyrim
launcher where if you click and drag it
actually moves the actual launcher
around as you can see will do that and
also will all do is nice rollovers and
will actually make the the buttons you
know do something which should be fun so
yeah I hope you enjoyed this tutorial
and I will see you guys next week
drop a like if you enjoyed this tutorial
um and yeah I'm actually on holidays
right now I've just started umm just
started school holidays so um you guys
should expect some more videos on the
way I've really tired today because I
went to bed late last night so I'm sorry
if this tutorial wasn't enthusiastic
enough for you also daylight saving time
in Australia happened it will in other
words it didn't happen it went backwards
so this episode might be an hour late
for some of you but it'll be 9 & p.m.
Australian Eastern Standard Time not
Australian Eastern Daylight Time so now
as Australian Eastern Standard Time so
keep that in mind
um but I'm actually working on an
exciting new series for you guys it's
gonna be a game series and so it's not
gonna be like a game develop and it's
actually gonna be like a like a Call of
Duty series so that should be fun and
obviously not one more for three because
that game sucks but it will I'm really
excited for it and I hope you guys will
also like it but um for now I'll see you
guys later
so drop a like if you liked the video
and yeah later guys